[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour à
tous bienvenue sur sensation en
association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec France costard
directeur programmateur de la maryse à
Trappes bonjour bonjour alors votre
salle de spectacle est située à Trappes
à 50 ans en Yvelines tout au long de
l'année vous proposez une programmation
éclectique et qui se veut pour tous les
goûts quels sont vos ambitions justement
en termes de culture sur le territoire
nous avons promotion moi j'aime bien le
mot populaire
je pense pas ça c'est pas Galway c'est
voilà on a une programmation pour tous
tout le monde peut s'y retrouver et
c'est ce côté là que qu'on recherche
voilà enfin avec avec l'équipe
municipale qui est en place on a un
travail surtout toujours avec une
thématique cette année c'était
engagez-vous voilà et chaque année avant
c'était l'identité et on a donc et on
décline voilà une formation comme ça et
puis on a également les jeunes amateurs
culturels ce sont des jeunes qui partent
avec nous en festival ils sont venus
avec moi au Grand-Bornand c'est un
festin jeune public cet été
avec moi à Bourges et puis d'autres
festivals ils ont la même etc et puis
ils découvrent des spectacles et nous
les ramène donc la formation c'est pas
que nous il y a aussi des jeunes
amateurs culturels les Jacques et puis
voilà et ce qu'on veut bah c'est quelque
chose qui nous ressemble du territoire
on a une sorte de mélange nous surtout à
Trappes voilà une vraie mixité et voilà
il faut que ça nous ressemble on peut
estimer finalement que la culture prend
une place importante finalement dans le
territoire de trappe et de 50 ans en
Yvelines grâce à la Meurice mais pas
seulement justement à travers des
actions culturelles que la Merise met en
place à travers les actions culturelles
à travers à la fois aussi des
partenariats on a lancé un partenariat
avec la Comédie Française on est la
première ville à avoir lancé ça donc
c'est pas rien la Communauté française
voilà vient travailler avec la ville de
Trappes il y a toute une symbolique
derrière et puis bon on a des bastions
aussi de l'impro du stand-up voilà après
après sur le territoire on n'est pas les
seuls on travaille aussi avec la scène
nationale je veux dire voilà
donc vous êtes en corrélation finalement
avec les autres
alors on va parler justement de la
programmation de votre salle de
spectacle on va commencer avec le
spectacle 1983 qui sera le 29 mars à la
Meurice alors de quoi va parler
justement cette pièce de théâtre alors
on va revenir un peu en arrière a été 83
beaucoup de violences policières des des
manifestations qui qui voilà démarche
qui viennent justement de tous ces
problématiques rencontrées par des
jeunes générations
issues de l'immigration et puis une
volonté aux Minguettes de mettre en
place une marche voilà la marche pour
l'égalité et c'est une marche qui
partira et qui viendra jusqu'à Paris et
c'est le lancement justement de
de justement touche pas à mon pote et
donc une pièce d'aide qui s'est montée
c'est la compagnie Nova qui a monté ça
et alors moi je l'ai pas vu parce que
c'est en créa voilà donc on l'a signé
d'entrée puisque on connaît bien cette
compagnie on voulait travailler avec eux
et puis après au travers de ça on a
aussi on a une expo de photos de
quelqu'un à madougate qui a suivi
justement cette manif voilà qui est du
territoire qui est de Fontenay et
qui voulait justement bah
suivre cette génération et puis prendre
des photos donc on a décidé de prendre
une trentaine de clichés et les exposer
aussi à la Meurice dans le hall donc
voilà donc c'est pas seulement je fais
du spectacle pour du spectacle il y a au
travers de ça ce qu'on disait auparavant
il y a de l'action voilà il y a des
rencontres avec lycéens Amadou va
rencontrer des jeunes enfin leur parler
de ce que c'était à cette époque là et
puis on a différents invités et voilà
c'est avec une belle thématique le
théâtre c'est aussi créer justement de
l'échange avec avec le public et du coup
vous allez très bien le faire le 29 mars
un spectacle marionnettes et d'ombre est
prévue le 8 avril avec un goûter prévu
donc pour les enfants qui viendront voir
le spectacle à partir de quel âge
peut-on venir voir cette cette pièce de
théâtre et que va-t-elle raconter ah je
dirais des 4 ans voilà et puis de toute
façon vous savez à n'importe quel âge
vous avez des choses et des perceptions
qui sont différentes mais des quatre ans
vous pouvez voir les choses et puis même
quand vous êtes adulte on est tout un
message derrière les cages je sais pas
si vous connaissez cette petite chaîne
qui a été envoyée dans l'espace le
premier être humain avoir été envoyé un
espace c'était les cas c'est un chien
abandonné dans les rues et que l'on va
récupérer ils l'ont envoyé dans l'espace
donc voilà donc c'est l'histoire à la
fois marionnettes à la fois théâtre
Élisée et en même temps avec du mapping
sur l'histoire de ce petit chien voilà
enfin cette chienne alors qu'apporte
justement l'art du spectacle à la
jeunesse selon vous est-ce que votre
ambition c'est justement de proposer de
plus en plus de spectacles accessibles à
la jeune génération ou en tout cas des
des spectacles familiaux donc on
commence à travailler dès l'âge de 6
mois ça peut paraître aberrant mais on
fait même des spectacles pour à partir
de 6 mois voilà ça a été a fait c'est
déjà cette année on le refera l'année
prochaine voilà dès la crèche pourquoi
si on amène les plus jeunes à fréquenter
les théâtres à aller voir du spectacle
vivant de l'art justement ils vont être
sensibilisés à ça et tout au long de
leur vie automatiquement elles sont
attirées par ça voilà donc oui il faut
les former très jeune une grosse marque
l'inconnu avec un gros m et puis un
clown ils font tout ils ont tout compris
ils attiraient plus jeunes voilà parce
que après quand on s'habituait à manger
ça on continue et bah bonjour de la
culture voilà la chose écrans allons
voir du vivant et dès les plus jeunages
je vais lâcher ma console et je vais
aller voir un peu quelque chose d'autre
quoi alors justement donc la chambre des
écrans pour pour le 8 avril finalement
pour un spectacle en famille à partir de
4 ans vous vous l'avez dit un peu de
musique maintenant avec les solistes de
la ville-dieu le 15 avril qu'est-ce qui
attend le public pour cette soirée alors
il y a des concerts pédagogiques
organisés le jeudi et vendredi on reçoit
les 12
13 communes de l'agglo je ne compte pas
parce qu'on avait déjà sur place donc 12
communes de l'agglo on reçoit tous les
scolaires voilà ils viennent tous à la
Merise voilà
découvrir ce que c'est qu'un orchestre
classique et découvrir donc ça fait
partie aussi du travail sur le
territoire et pas uniquement bordé à la
ville de trappe la même excuse
intervient surtout le territoire donc
c'est une corréalisation avec eux et le
samedi c'est un concert voilà donc
famille et toutes les familles qui ont
pu assister au concept pédagogique tous
les enfants sont bien sûr invités à ce
concert et puis tous les gens bien sûr
du territoire aussi mais c'est justement
une volonté également donc de à la fois
de la ville de Trappes mais aussi de la
Meurice du coup de de faire découvrir
justement des artistes du territoire des
artistes soit émergents ou des jeunes
artistes du territoire dès que c'est
possible je dois mettre en avant des
artistes oui c'est le but quoi c'est on
a un rôle à la fois de de diffusion mais
aussi de découvrir de jeunes talents
si on peut aider vous voyez bien
maintenant on a plus besoin de l'aider
c'est aussi voilà on a été les premiers
à la faire passer elle est du territoire
et c'était bien justement de la faire
passer à ce moment-là donc maintenant
elle est devenue beaucoup plus
importante et passe dans des Zénith mais
voilà donc c'est important à ce
moment-là de montrer bah la force qu'on
a sur le territoire je vous rattrape que
ça soit il s'adoune bien que ça soit
également Alban
Ivanov qui a du territoire voilà
Omar Sy tous ces artisans on en a pas
mal on a pas mal
alors on peut s'appuyer dessus les
mettre en avant
qui a un artiste un rap de rappeur
émergent on poursuit la programmation
avec le spectacle dans la solitude des
champs de coton le 20 avril pouvez-vous
nous en dire un peu plus sur cette pièce
de théâtre c'est une pièce de coltes
donc dans la suite de celui des champs
de coton c'est tout un c'est un duo
entre
quelqu'un qui se drogue et son dealer et
de voir qui dépend de l'un ou de l'autre
et il y a toute une phase de dessus donc
c'est avec dedans il y a Yvan Moran et
Elodie à chaque fois
c'est Xavier voilà donc le client et sur
des décors de Anki Bilal donc c'est une
création voilà 2022 et
qui à sa place et qui est nommé dans les
Molières voilà donc ça vient la peine
d'être
découvert et voilà alors on va passer au
mois de mai avec Dany et Albert Larry
qui posent une question comment faire
disparaître son père alors pourquoi
avoir décidé de programmer cette pièce à
la Meuse bah la magie ça marche très
bien chez nous voilà de plus en plus les
gens m'en demandent donc on avait eu
déjà que ça soit gus ou également on a
eu
comment le Québécois
mais voilà et donc l'intérêt c'était de
d'amener encore un magicien ce qui est
marrant avec Dany et larys c'est que
c'est la vieille génération qui a font
la nouvelle génération et donc voilà
tout le monde connaît Danny
grand illusionniste de des plus grands
camarades du monde avec Patrick
Sébastien et donc on va découvrir son
fils et cet univers là
donc voilà je trouvais ça marrant de Luc
Langevin c'est revenu le Québécois qui
est venu et donc voilà donc la magie ça
marche très très bien et les gens aiment
beaucoup ça et le plateau s'y prête
énormément on a un très grand plateau
avec une très grande hauteur sous
plafond beaucoup de coulisses voilà et
ça permet on a même beaucoup de
magiciens qui viennent préparer leur
show voilà je peux le dire l'année
prochaine on ouverte saison on aura les
French twin qui viennent chez nous en
résidence travailler voilà donc on a
aussi beaucoup de magiciens et on pourra
justement en reparler de toute cette
programmation très très éclectique qui
de la programmation justement a été
retrouvée sur le site trap mag.fr merci
beaucoup Francis costard d'avoir été
avec nous sur sensation donc je rappelle
que vous êtes directeur programmateur de
la Merise attrape et pour revoir ou
réécouter cette émission rendez-vous sur
notre site et notre application radio
sensation
[Musique]